[Music]
dynamic in your
face and always moving
forward no City looks more to the Future
than New York City the Big Apple grew
out of
water The Secret Story of its success
lies hidden under its two rivers and its
Mighty
Harbor
this is one of the most notorious
stretches of water on the New York
Waterfront imagine if we could empty the
oceans letting the water drain away to
reveal the secrets of the
seafloor now we
can using accurate
data and astonishing
technology to to bring light once again
to a lost
world how does the horror of 9/11 lead
to an extraordinary Discovery from the
birth of
America the most Grizzly and bloodiest
event of the entire Revolutionary War
what does this offshore wreck reveal
about the city's explosive growth people
talked about the forest of
p and what sank this huge us warship
just miles from New
[Music]
York the largest city in America
300 square
miles 8 and A5 million
[Music]
people
tenacious
powerful
confident all of it built from scratch
in just 400
years and the secret to its
success it's River and
harbor in the waters around New York
archaeologists have located thousands of
wrecks time capsules that can reveal
this City's incredible story in a new
light one in
particular what is this strange wreck
and why is it
here
[Music]
as New Yorkers recover from the shock of
911 the ruins of the Twin Towers reveal
a secret from the very start of their
City's story little did we know that
from this terrible tragedy there would
be a major
Discovery a secret from the
past by 2010 1.8 million tons of debris
have been
removed the construction of a high
security parking garage is
underway they decided to make that
entrance underground so they dug down
down deeper than they had
before 22 ft beneath the
tarmac in the shadows of the Twin
Towers the remnants of an ancient
[Music]
ship at the construction site at Ground
Zero a rare find what we can see is
believed to be half of a
ship construction halts and a team of
archa ologists rushes to Ground
Zero the principal investigator Warren
Reese it was right there right where the
security area is for parking at the
World Trade
Center when Warren arrives only part of
the ship is exposed its Secrets still
hidden under the mud the history of this
particular vessel might fill in
tremendous gaps in our knowledge about
the history of New York City
itself to find out more Warren's team
scans the excavated site with high
accuracy Laser
Technology combining the highresolution
3D data with cuttingedge computer
Imaging we can turn back time and drain
Ground
Zero
to reveal an astonishing Subterranean
secret layers of Earth crumble
away 22 ft underground in the heart of
Manhattan the flattened wreck of a
wooden
ship
it's 30 ft long and its wooden structure
is roughly
hee we never seen a vessel just like
this one it was not only rare it's one
of a
kind what is this ship and what's it
doing beneath the heart of Manhattan
more than 500 yard from the
shoreline to find out Reese and his team
need to learn its age
taking a closer look inside the
wood they find well-preserved tree
rings they reveal that the timber was
felled in
1773 or soon
after it was like a time capsule it's a
secret time
capsule in America the 1770s mean only
one thing
Revolution what we have is a a vessel
that's been hiding underneath New York
City that's from the Revolutionary
period back then New York is home to
just 255,000 people but the quality of
its harbor has already made it one of
America's most successful
ports its strategic importance puts New
York firmly in the crosshairs of
Britain's King
George when the American Revolution
begins in
1775 just a year later a huge British
Invasion Force drives George
Washington's Army out of the
city could this ship have been part of
the
battle going back to the drained
wreckage Clues
emerge
beneath the decking
327 pieces of
artillery including a cannon ball and 56
musket
[Music]
balls soldiers from one side or another
have clearly been on board this
ship then in the center of the wreck
Warren Reese's team discovers the
smallest of
Clues
[Music]
now this button was found in the
midships area of the vessel between some
frames and some planks and because of
that we know it was on the ship before
it was
buried the putter button is stamped with
the number 52 it's fallen from the
uniform of a soldier from the 52nd
Regiment of the British
army they were grenadiers which mean
they're very aggressive assault troops
pretty exciting to find this because
this ties the ship to a British soldier
in New York During the Revolution a
common Soldier who's lost their
button if this ship was used by some of
the most fearsome troops in the British
army what were they using it
for combining the scanning data with new
research by Texas A&M
University
we can resurrect the
[Music]
ship as her original form rises from the
dirt her full size becomes clear and her
striking
features 50 ft long her beam 18 ft with
the hull of a
rivercraft Just 4 ft deep and a small
Keel this is not an ocean goinging
vessel it's specifically designed for
use in sheltered Coastal
Waters it was able to get into shallow
water into little Coes up alongside
[Music]
ships a ship that's perfect for
operating within New York Harbor and
crewed by British grenadiers evidence
that she could be part of a little known
but brutal story
during the War British forces fed many
thousands of Americans to a horrifying
destination just 2 miles away off the
shores of
Brooklyn during the American Revolution
this was known as wallabout
Bay and it was the most lethal place
during the whole Revolution for the
Americans New York City still has its
Secrets its dark passed including the
most Grizzly and bloody bloodiest event
of the entire Revolutionary
War as the British try to quell the
uprising they capture thousands of
prisoners and Ferry them out onto the
Waters of wallabout
bay to a place known as hell
afloat a flotilla of festering British
ships overcrowded freezing cold old
poorly supplied and run by brutal
guards the diseases that swept through
just terrorized the men on
board most notorious of all the HMS
Jersey she would serve as potentially
the worst prison ship floating dungeon
in human
history Warren Reese believes that the
World Trade Center ship may play a role
in this dark chapter of New York's
history they needed boats to go back and
forth and to bring prisoners out and
this would have been a perfect vessel
for that they would have just stuffed
them in there even if they had to pack
them in sitting
down it might carry 100 people on
board the casualty figures are
staggering far worse than
9/11 historians estimate that 11,000 men
die on HMS Jersey alone twice as many
men died aboard the Jersey as were lost
in combat during the entirety of the
Revolutionary War it's
unimaginable a very dark chapter of
American
history
one last mystery remains about the
British fairy booat why was it found
under the heart of
[Music]
Manhattan America finally wins
Independence and New York changes fast
in the years after the American
Revolution New York very much uh is Like
a Phoenix Rising From the Ashes
politically and
economically at its heart a thriving
gawk that looks very different from the
city of
today we're in the middle of a modern
city here we in the lower districts of
Manhattan and about halfway down that
block was the original
Shoreline eager to improve their Harbor
New Yorkers build new
Wares extending the island of Manhattan
out into the
bay abandoned in the docks half sunk in
the mud the old British Ferry is Simply
Built around and
over centuries later the World Trade
Center Rises on top of the old
dockland and the ships that had
witnessed a America's bloody
[Music]
birth Commerce drives the city's
expansion and for Commerce location is
[Music]
everything facing the Roaring Atlantic
at the mouth of the Hudson
River New York's huge natural Harbor is
the perfect place for an international
Port miles of Shoreline in a protected
Bay from which and independent America
can trade with the
world in the 1800s more passengers and
cargo flow through New York than all
other us ports
combined there were so many sailing
vessels coming and going and docking
here that observers would describe it as
a forest of
masts but the city's ambition soon
outgrows The Fabulous Harbor provided by
Nature
just yards from bustling uptown
Manhattan evidence of an earth
shattering event that reshaped this
city just how far would New Yorkers go
to make their port the greatest on
Earth New York York Harbor's main
entrance is the verit Sano
[Music]
Narrows but there's a second gateway to
the Atlantic Long Island
Sound crucial to sustaining the frenzy
flow of
Commerce but it's obstructed by a
perilous stretch of the East
River
Hellgate in the 1850s one in 50 ships
are devoured here a terrifying
statistic James Delgado Maritime
archaeologist from search Incorporated
wants to learn more about the dangers of
Hellgate this early map is particularly
remarkable because it shows us
Hellgate with the the positions of a
number of rocks
marked islands and hidden reefs choke
the shipping
Lane churning the water into a
Maelstrom this is a challenging if not
dangerous area to
navigate a gauntlet to be
run among the many Perils of Hellgate
one monster looms large and
deadly flood rocks
nine acres of stone lurking just beneath
the
surface right at the heart of
Hellgate today the channel is still
dangerous the major obstacle was
basically right in the middle of the
road right off of here
but there's no sign of Flood Rock above
the
water does the ship devouring monster
lie beneath the
surface James takes to the
water okay sounds
good this is one of the most notorious
stretches of water on the New York water
FM what you would have been faced with
is all this fast moving water and it's
not just moving in One Direction it's
going back and forth It's swirling
around
rocks you sail through you lose the wind
and suddenly that movement of water
drags you right into the
teeth in search of Flood Rock the team
from Noah scans Hellgate with multi-beam
sonar firing sound waves into the murky
depths the return signal records the
shape of the features
beneath this is a real time image of the
bottom and you can see all the rubble
wow using the 3D multi-beam data and the
latest computer visualization technology
it's now possible to pull the plug on
the entire
Harbor to reveal a jaw-dropping
sight icons of the city as never seen
[Music]
before as the water recedes from the
East River the remains of Flood Rock
should come into
view but there's not a trace of the
Beast that is shown in the old charts
nine acres of rock have
vanished
[Music]
how buried in the
archives an incredible story of New
York's
self-confidence and
ambition this 1848 chart by the US Coast
survey is actually a working document it
was never published lished this is for
an engineer to figure out how best to
start dealing with this how do we pull
these teeth to make this a smoother ride
through backed by wealthy New York
Merchants the city fathers make a
decision the future of the city is at
stake Flood Rock has got to go it is the
beginning an age in which nothing was
deemed impossible if enough ingenuity
engineering and perhaps money was put
behind it as human beings work to
reshape the planet to their
purposes James discovers how the city's
Engineers planned to do
it by attacking the problem from
beneath first they sink a 70ft shaft
Into the Heart of the
island over nine long years miners dig
four miles of
tunnels and drill 15,000 bore
holes and in them they place a
staggering
150 tons of
explosives the Hellgate work is an epic
moment in the history of civil
engineering this is a moment in which
technology will triumph over
nature
on October the 10th
1885 50,000 people flocked to New York's
East River everybody's waiting for the
Big
Show Flood Rock is primed with
explosives and the Detonator is
pushed 7 million cubic feet of
pulverized Rock flies up up into the
Skies over New York
City the greatest explosion not only
that New York has seen but that the
world has seen up to that
time and when the spray clears Flood
Rock is
history leaving the riverbed looking
like a gravel
pit if you really want to think about
how New Yorkers have reconfigured and
reshaped their entire environment both
on land and in water I think the word
hutzpah is perfect for
that with its second entrance now secure
New York's shipping business increases
at an Ever faster
rate cargo ships move sugar spices
cotton machinery and construction
materials all to feed America's booming
economy New York expands dramatically in
the 19th century it's becoming the
Industrial and Commercial heart of the
United
States by the 1880s the City's
population is more than a
million and its waters are getting
crowded dangerously
so in the wild Atlantic just a few miles
Beyond new New York Harbor what can one
strange offshore wreck tell us of the
pace of trade through the waters of New
York and the Peril facing those pursuing
the American
dream before Daybreak on March 14th
1886 the SS Oregon is nearing the end of
a 3,000m voyage from
England transporting her cargo and over
600 passengers through the dark approach
to New York
Harbor it's a calm
night just 60 miles stand between her
and her final
[Music]
destination but at first light a lookout
from Fire Island signal station reports
her masts drifting off
[Music]
course moments
later the Oregon
disappears and never arrives in New
York what happens to
her and all the people on board out in
the
darkness as flat as this seems this is a
dangerous section of
ocean
there are many disasters that happen
within the reach of this light's beams
but every once in a while there comes a
big disaster in which a large ship is
lost for over 130 years Oregon has Lain
shrouded by the
Atlantic the waters off the New York
coast are dark cold and often
murky the ocean has cons sealed her
Secrets but now that's
changing off the southern shore of Fire
Island the Ferdinand R Hassler goes in
search of wreckage you are clear to turn
around and make another pass for
hundreds of years the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric administration's Coast
survey has been charting and recharting
these Waters we're about 12 nautical
miles south of Fire Island
and we're about to go right on top of
that multibeam scanners in the ship's
Hull emit sonar
pulses and we use this technology to
very accurately and precisely map
features on the ocean
floor oh wow there it
is look at that that's
awesome based upon this detailed
three-dimensional data we can bring the
Oregon and her story
back into the
light first a towering structure of
Tangled
metal the water receding
further the Oregon has never seen
before
she's taken a beating from the ocean her
insides are exposed to the elements
allowing us to examine what type of ship
she
is though her masks were seen from
ashore they must have been
supplementary Oregon isn't a Sal ship in
fact she represents a revolution in
shipping she is a
steamer beneath her four-story High
steam engine the remains of nine boilers
each 16 ft wide this thing is a behemoth
with so many fires going that it's
consuming massive amounts of
coal and towards her Stern a huge screw
propeller 24 ft
wide this is the corpse of an
athlete a ship built with one thing in
mind
speed but
[Music]
why the answer is part of the DNA of New
York City
itself
immigrants folks from all around the
world that came for opportunity and for
this dream that New York City was more
than 70% of immigrants Bound for America
arrive in New York New York is the
Gateway as Lincoln said it was the front
door by the late
1800s 650,000 immigrants arrive every
year and up to 20,000 boats a year
maneuver through the harbor and everyone
is in a hurry is a time of rampant
capitalism great fortunes are being made
profit is
everything the waters are just alive
with
vessels faster ships mean more trade and
bigger
profits time is
money the Quest for profit leads to an
extraordinary technological race to
build ships that will cross the Atlantic
faster and
faster
the early days of ocean steam are
Cutthroat you have entrepreneurs who are
battling It Out on the
Ocean by the 1870s and into the 1880s
that's when you begin to see the birth
of truly magnificent ocean Steamers
Greyhounds of the sea
leviathans the British operated gon line
builds the Oregon in 1881 to boost its
New York express
service and she's Cutting
Edge it has the largest steam engine yet
put into one of these
ships consuming over 200 tons of coal a
day her boilers generate upwards of
12,000
horsepower driving the huge screw
propeller that thrusts Oregon forward at
an astonishing 18
knots in April 18 1884 she crosses the
Atlantic in under 6 and 1/2 days
slashing 13 hours off the Record it's
something that nobody had thought could
be
done Oregon claims the prize and earns
the nickname Greyhound of the
Atlantic so what took down such a
powerful
machine return to the drained wreck
there's a clue disguised by Decades of
[Music]
Decay on her port side a section of the
hull is more crumpled than anywhere
else something must have ripped a hole
right
here but
what the degradation means it's
impossible to tell from the wreckage
alone an article from The New York Times
holds the
[Music]
answer Oregon is a victim of New York's
heaving
waterways the risk of getting into a
collision is actually shockingly
High combining This research with the
evidence from the drained wreck we can
piece together the final
moments at 4:30 in the morning Oregon is
Bound for New York under a full head of
steam it's a dark night they're lining
up and heading towards the port they can
see the lights along the Long Island
Shore the Fire Island light is
brilliantly
[Music]
lit a light appears on her port
side it's another ship heading right for
them and it strikes them dramatically on
the
side then the other ship backs off and
disappears the ocean is pouring Into the
Heart of
[Music]
Oregon over eight frantic hours nearby
boats rescue every passenger on board
the
Oregon their dreams of a new life In
America still
intact but the mighty Oregon has
suffered a fatal
blow this Greyhound of the Atlantic has
been gored and sunk just off the
entrance to the
city while Oregon never makes it to Port
thousands more liners do
Ellis Island opens in
1892 12 million new Americans pour
through its
Halls ocean liners flood the harbor
beckoning a golden
age in just a century New York's
population grows from 60,000 to 3 and5
million by 1900 it's the largest city in
the Western
Hemisphere drawing the eyes of the
world including those who would try and
take her
down 40 mil from New York off the shores
of Long
Island what sank this giant and how does
her sinking reveal New York's
vulnerability at the dawn of the 20th
century
in the summer of
1917 America is at
War transatlantic convoys carrying
troops and supplies to Europe are key to
the Allies hopes of
success protected by warships like the
USS San
Diego 500 ft long over 13,000 tons armor
plated with 40 guns of up to 8 in
and multiple watertight bulkheads to
make her
Unsinkable on July 19th
1918 she's approaching New York to pick
up a
convoy at 11:05 a.m. just outside the
harbor she is rocked by a huge
explosion within 20 minutes the had
sunk San Diego was the only major US
Navy warship lost in the Great War it
happens to lie just a few miles from the
coast of New
York so what
happened a team from the US Navy has
reopened the case led by archaeologist
Alexis katsanis the question has
lingered for over a century what San
Diego to find out Navy divers explore
the wreckage of this sunken
[Music]
Warrior but it's impossible to see the
whole picture through the murky
[Music]
Waters working with the University of
Delaware Alexis deploys three
dimensional scanning equipment to map
San Diego's structure on the
seafloor this project is the first time
we're getting comprehensive remote
sensing
data combining this new data with the
latest computer imaging technology we
can do something impossible before
now reveal in perfect detail the wreck
of a US casualty of the Great
War the Sandy Diego comes into the light
for the first time in a 100
years it's the beautiful Sleek shape of
her 500t hole that appears
first the steel structure is in
remarkable condition for her
age apart from
this towards her Stern a section of the
hull that's damaged
this is the blast site eroded by Decades
of
Decay but it appears to be below the
water
[Music]
line if something hit the ship it was
beneath the
[Music]
surface the team studies the historical
records there's no suggestion that
engine malfunction or onboard ordinance
caused the blast reinforcing The View
that it could have been caused by
something more
[Music]
Sinister advances in technology mean
German OTS can now cross the
Atlantic this is a a new era where
submarine warfare is taking over the war
was brought to New York
Shores by the 1900s New York is the
planet's busiest
port an irresistible Target for the
Imperial German
Navy if you're an enemy of the United
States what is a more symbolic Target
than New York
City the team wonders if a torpedo from
a boat could have caused the
explosion to answer the question they
calculate the original size of the blast
hole what damage is related to that
original point of impact and that
original
explosion they find a report from a Navy
diver who visited the wreck in
1918 he says he was along the bottom on
the port side around the number four
Smoke Stack he estimates the cavity to
be just 5T wide
well that corresponds to being right
below the armor belt which makes
sense using this data we can reconstruct
the original blast
hole could it have been caused by a
[Music]
torpedo the team models the damage that
World War I torpedo payloads cause and
get a
surprise it became rather evident that
the Torpedoes were simply too large of a
weapon They Carried too large of a
charge and would have resulted in a hole
that was Far larger than 5 or 6
ft they wonder if it was a mine
incredibly archives from the German
government reveal uots were ordered to
lay mines outside New York
Harbor they knew that it was an
important area for shipping for the
United States and
allies but they discover standard German
mines known as type four also inflict a
blast hole larger than
[Music]
5T then a key
Insight by
1918 Germany is running short of
explosives the Germans by the end of the
war were using diminished
charges and allowing for the reduced
charge in a type four mine it produces a
blast hole close to 5 ft
wide it appears to be a
match San Diego was almost certainly hit
by a small German
mine but there's another
question the hole is still
tiny how could it sink a 500 ft long
ship in just 20
minutes and flip her upside
down 40 mil from New York the drained
wreck of the San Diego reveals another
piece of the
[Music]
puzzle understanding the weapon is only
one part of a larger picture we want to
understand the whole sequence of events
that occurred and how the ship
HCK watertight bulkheads and doors are
specifically designed to stop the spread
of water and keep this warship
upright but somehow San Diego turned
upside
down she sank through just 100 ft of
water not enough for her to roll on The
Descent she must have capsized at the
surface how did a small small hole in a
watertight section of this ship leave
her lying prone on the
seafloor Alexis and his colleagues are
sure that water must have penetrated
further into her
Hull we need to understand how this
happened how did we get to the point
where instead of Simply sinking the ship
turned it onto
herself analysis shows that even with
substantial flooding San Diego wouldn't
capsize baffled the team studies San
Diego's structure looking for signs of
weakness so here we can see a plan of
the gun deck of USA San
Diego but plans are no match for
inspecting a real
warship a contemporary of the San Diego
although a few years older is the
Cruiser USS Olympic
the oldest steel warship still
afloat examining her internal structure
the team makes a
breakthrough then we realize that the
fact that she was coal powered was
critical and crucial to our
determination of how she capsized coal
stored on Deck has to be delivered to
the engine rooms below so this shoot
would have been similar to like the one
we would find on San Diego it would have
allowed coal to be deposited all the way
through to the coal bunkers and even
though you can close it it's still not
watertight this weakness hadn't been
clear on the San Diego's plans there
were additional entry points we were not
factoring
in the watertight bulkheads prevent
seawater from flooding the entire Hull
but these shoots and a network of vents
gave it another
route and so water coming in through
through the gun deck would have
permeated through these shoots into the
coal bunkers and from there onto the
engine rooms and the boiler rooms and
throughout the
vest by examining San Diego's wreckage
and piecing together the clues we're
able to tell her complete story for the
very first
[Music]
time the USS San Diego is headed for New
York
The Horizon is
clear but there's danger lurking beneath
the
water a German ubo has laid a
Minefield San Diego rushes against
one water spewed into the air and it
started then flooding the engineering
and Boiler Room
spaces as she lives s water pours onto
the gun deck from the port
side rapidly penetrating the ship via
the coal shoots and vents tipping her
further within a few moments she had
capsized and was on her way to the
bottom all but six of her 1100 strong
crew
survived but San Diego sinks to her
watery Grave Just miles from the heart
of New York
City a heavyweight victim of a
calculated
[Music]
attack draining New York City reveals
stories of
conflict
immigration and ruthless
ambition today the spirit and success of
this remarkable City still invites enemy
attack to which New York gives a
familiar
[Music]
reply